we want to be top of mind when someone
thinks about how should I invest my
money what service should I use where is
a good place to start so we want our
service to be synonymous with the active
investing my name is Vlad 10m I'm the
co-founder of Robin Hood and I'm 28
years old before we started Robin Hood
we were in New York doing enterprise
software for hedge funds and large
institutions we were building technology
that made it easier for banks and hedge
funds to process trades completely
automatically without any manual
intervention and this allowed them to
place trades with no cost basically
placing a trade is as simple and as
electronic as sending an email so after
we saw that we wondered why is this
technology why are these tools not
available to consumers why are consumers
still being charged seven to ten dollars
a trade for a purely electronic
transaction and this was around the end
of 2011 when the whole Occupy Wall
Street movement was gaining a lot of
traction and we saw that people our age
had a lot of distrust for the
establishment distrust for Wall Street
and here we were we had all this
knowledge and we understood that the
markets were such a powerful tool we
wanted to make a company that actually
stood for the consumer and brought Wall
Street and made it actually useful and
working in the best interest of normal
everyday people the biggest mistake is
leaving a lot of your money in your
savings account one thing that might not
be obvious is in the current interest
rate environment with inflation your
money in a savings account is basically
doing nothing you're essentially losing
a few percent per year just due to
inflation and the stock market over the
past hundred years has returned an
average of 10 percent per year so if you
have a super long term outlook we
believe that the stock market is
actually a really really good place for
savings income